[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de france24 2020
es un año que se quedará grabado en la
memoria colectiva la pandemia alteró
nuestro estilo de vida y nos obligó a
mantenernos en distancia y a quedarnos
en casa pero el confinamiento pensado
para proteger la salud de las
poblaciones se convirtió para miles de
mujeres en un encierro peligroso apto
para la violencia doméstica y para la
violencia de género la vulnerabilidad de
la salud física y mental de las mujeres
quedó en evidencia donde antes había
riesgo ahora hay consecuencias de la
desprotección a los derechos humanos y
el hogar como hemos reportado en
múltiples ocasiones dejó de ser el lugar
más seguro para las personas
para muchas mujeres y niñas la amenaza
es mayor donde deberían estar más
seguras que es en su propia casa esto
dijo antonio guterres el secretario
general de la onu a principios de abril
cuando pidió respetar el confinamiento y
detener los conflictos para enfocarnos
en la lucha contra el coronavirus dijo
también algo que siempre ha sido cierto
la violencia no se limita al campo de
batalla los confinamientos y las
cuarentenas son esenciales para suprimir
el kobe pero pueden atrapar a mujeres
con parejas abusivas el programa de
naciones unidas para el desarrollo
publicó los siguientes datos
desde abril de 2020 en 29 países de
américa latina y el caribe se
establecieron 177 medidas para teclear
los abusos contra las mujeres dentro del
contexto de la pandemia se reforzaron
los canales de ayuda los refugios el
patrullaje y las judicialización es
entre otras disposiciones pero la
violencia de género sigue saliendo a
flote en casa y cada vez más el programa
de las naciones unidas para el
desarrollo ha descrito la situación como
una olla a presión una realidad
aumentada por los mayores niveles de
estrés económico la movilidad
restringida y el acceso reducido a los
servicios los contextos que antes eran
de potencial abuso pasaron a ser
escenarios de violencia especialmente
contra las mujeres y los niños la
evidencia de estos casos no es fácil de
obtener pero en lo que han recabado las
organizaciones de derechos humanos los
patrones generales de abuso aumentaron
en 2020 eso se ve en reportes de policía
en centros de salud y en refugios además
queda consignado en las líneas
telefónicas de ayuda que cada vez suenan
más y eso sin considerar lo que se cree
es un amplio sub registro de casos por
temor de las víctimas
pero recopiló las tendencias de
violencia de género basándose en esas
llamadas argentinas 137 y 144 brazil 180
colombia 155 república dominicana 212
guatemala mil 572 paraguay 137 perú
tiene la línea gris muestra el nivel de
llamadas mensuales en 2019 y la línea
roja oscura muestra el volumen en 2020
la línea vertical punteada corresponde
al mes de marzo cuando las medidas de
cuarentena comenzaron a imponerse en la
región por ejemplo en argentina las
llamadas subieron 32 por ciento y los
pedidos de víctimas directas aumentaron
en un 127 por ciento en pero el aumento
fue del 48% entre abril y julio desde
washington de senos a campaña de luis
felipe lópez-calva subsecretario general
de naciones unidas y director regional
del programa de las naciones unidas para
el desarrollo para américa latina y el
caribe gracias luis felipe y aumentó el
número de las llamadas a las líneas de
ayuda para los casos de violencia
doméstica en la región háblenos de ese
fenómeno
primero muchas gracias por la
oportunidad efectivamente hay una
preocupación muy grande por el
incremento en los indicadores de
violencia doméstica y en general de
violencia contra mujeres y niñas es en
general que vemos cuáles las condiciones
sociales que determinan y que tienen que
ver con normas que tienen que ver con
las relaciones de poder en el hogar y
demás que es usar esto exacerbado por el
hecho del confinamiento entonces el
confinamiento que hace hace que se
convive en un espacio cerrado que se
genere más estrés que se genere una
situación muy compleja que exacerba los
ya preocupantes patrones de violencia
hemos observado incrementos de entre 20
y 50 por ciento en las llamadas a las
instancias de ayuda en algunos casos es
hacia la parte legal en otros casos es
para asistencia psicológica pero
realmente un indicador que nos preocupa
desde desde el perú desde las naciones
unidas
junto con mujeres también tratando de
rápidamente ayudar a los gobiernos a
implementar medidas en esa dirección
louis pero no es estrés es cultura
machista podemos echarle la culpa a la
ansiedad o esto es más bien una
evidencia de un machismo preexistente
que justifica el maltrato y que se
exacerba con la pandemia
usted está tocando exactamente el punto
central y por eso fui muy cuidadoso en
mi primera mi primer comentario de decir
que esto exacerba los patrones
existentes de ninguna manera podemos
justificar por el tema del estrés porque
el estrés se les ocurre a todos los
descubre a los niños a los adultos por
supuesto que eso se ha incrementado y
eso interactúa con las condiciones
preexistentes que son por ejemplo normas
sociales que justifican este tipo de
comportamiento del trabajo aquí no
solamente tiene que ver con proteger de
que esto ocurra y de sancionar cuando
esto ocurre se trata de algo mucho más
complejo pero importantísimo que es
cambiar la cultura machista la cultura
en donde esto es permitido las encuestas
que se han hecho el acecho banco mundial
has hecho la usb en distintos países y
también naciones unidas- nosotros como
pedí de sacamos un índice de normas
sociales recientemente nuestro último
reporte global de desarrollo humano en
donde nos preocupa desde el punto de
vista formal e informal
a qué me refiero alguna vista formal
vemos países donde ha habido regresiones
en la legislación que trata de prevenir
este tipo de comportamiento pero de pone
vista de las reglas informales que es
esto las normas sociales la cultura
patriarcal la cultura machista que
justifica este tipo de comportamiento y
tenemos que cambiar el lenguaje tenemos
que cambiar la forma como esas cosas se
comunican por ejemplo cambiando los a
los roles que vemos en la televisión en
las series de televisión los roles que
se difunden en la música que escuchamos
el lenguaje que utilizamos los que
tenemos alguna influencia en la opinión
pública es un tema mucho más complejo y
tenemos que trabajar en todos esos
frentes para poder tener una incidencia
sobre las normas
sociales y el comportamiento cultural
que está detrás de la ex socia de
evasión de estos de este fenómeno y
estaría totalmente de acuerdo el estrés
y el confinamiento exacerban un problema
preexistente muy grave y que requiere
atención inmediata de toda la sociedad
claro y es que ya al inicio de la
primera ola de la pandemia se registró
un aumento de la violencia doméstica y
quedó claro que el hogar no es siempre
un lugar seguro le pregunto cómo ha sido
el fenómeno cuando el mundo experimenta
una nueva etapa de la crisis como es
ahora versus al inicio y qué cambios han
visto a ustedes
bueno algunos cambios positivos y otros
no tan positivos los cambios positivos
tienen que ver con mucha más acción
pública mucho más
[Música]
y muchos más mecanismos de apoyo y ayuda
a las víctimas hemos reforzado por
ejemplo en el contexto de una iniciativa
muy importante de la unión europea y el
sistema de naciones unidas que la
iniciativa spotlight en donde hay un
grupo interagencial del sistema de
naciones unidas con el apoyo de la unión
europea trabajando en distintos países
ciertamente en países de latinoamérica y
se ha reenfocado en el esfuerzo hacia el
tema de la violencia en el contexto del
confinamiento entonces hay medidas
importantes desde la parte positiva a la
parte negativa es que seguimos viendo un
incremento en estos indicadores y muy
importante que en algunas encuestas
recientes se ha visto un reforzamiento
en algunos casos de esas normas es decir
una justificación precisa en el deporte
en algunos casos por las razones que
usted mencionaba está justificación de
la violencia por la situación en la que
estamos viviendo
de tensión y confinamiento es
absolutamente inaceptable y tenemos que
trabajar mucho en esto de que no se
normalice esa violencia sino todo lo
contrario que sigamos trabajando lo como
la anomalía social que es y que sigamos
trabajando en el cambio de estas normas
sociales profundamente bueno pero si
pese a las medidas se siguió aumentando
la violencia entonces esas medidas
aplicadas no son suficientes o no se
trabajaron con suficiente ímpetu los
estados en que fallaron
yo creo que los estados están
reaccionando en la medida de sus
capacidades y nosotros estamos apoyando
y esa es la parte positiva porque
realmente se ha logrado establecer
muchos mecanismos de respuesta más
rápida se han logrado establecer
mecanismos de protección yo creo que la
parte que está fallando y ahí yo creo
que no es una responsabilidad de los
estados sino de la sociedad es el cambio
de las normas yo creo que si algo puede
dar esta situación tan grave que estamos
viendo del confinamiento y la violencia
asociada
es es una aumentar la visibilidad de
este problema y que nos acelere el
cambio cultural que necesitamos eso es
lo que yo creo que es lo más complicado
es eso atribuiría yo
y la lenta reacción más que la respuesta
a los estados a la respuesta de la
sociedad en términos de los cambios de
las normas culturales que es algo mucho
más complejo pero lo que se trabaja no
yo sí creo que si hay una acción
decidida como lo está viendo por parte
de instancias de distintas instancias
públicas y de la sociedad en general
podemos tomar este proceso tan
lamentable como una oportunidad para
acelerar ese cambio cultural bueno y
cuáles son los patrones de abuso ya para
finalizar que aumentaron en ese contexto
que ustedes llaman una olla a presión
bueno son los determinantes que por
mucho tiempo han sido analizados y que
han exacerbado por ejemplo las las
mujeres en el mercado laboral se han
visto más afectadas que los hombres
estaban en trabajos más vulnerables que
han perdido empleo de manera más
es importante que los hombres y eso se
refleja también en una tensión mayor
desde el punto de vista económico
entonces hay una razón económica para
provocar este tipo de tensión hay una
razón como lo decíamos social que es
este tema de la exacerbación de las
normas del confinamiento que se refleja
en el confinamiento y hay una
[Música]
en general una tendencia de ser al final
en la violencia de género es una
relación de poder y es muy lamentable
ver el tipo de violencia económica de
tipo de violencia verbal física y
obviamente el tipo de violencia sexual
yo creo que todas éstas han sido
desafortunadamente incrementadas con
esta situación y se tiene que trabajar
muy rápido en el empoderamiento social
comunitario económico de las mujeres
para la recuperación para que estén en
una mejor situación pero insisto en
realidad está la esencia de esto no
cambiará hasta que podamos hacer este
cambio cultural
pues gracias a usted ya nuestros
televidentes una vez más por estar con
nosotros sigan en france 24
[Música]